why was it important to focus on this
story and why was it important not to
make the movie that so many people
typically make about death row which is
the last-minute pardon I think when when
Alan and I first read David's story in
The New Yorker David gran what was so
clear to us besides that inchoate rage
that it really engendered in both of us
was that it seemed to be a catalogue of
everything that was wrong with the
criminal justice system it was junk
science
it was prosecutorial withholding of
Excalibur Tory evidence jailhouse
snitches and change for reduced
sentences most of all it was about
poverty and its effect on the inability
to therefore get proper representation
which inevitably would lead to the bad
result you know and I remember I had
read a book actually by Brian Stevenson
saying that you have a better chance to
if you are guilty if you are rich and
guilty you have a better chance than if
you were poor and innocent so so
therefore I we took on this with an
agenda but I will also say that it was
because we saw in it a human face we saw
the story of Liz Gilbert and and Todd
Willingham and I believed that that the
idea of trying to talk about what that
act of kindness and what a personal
connection can do between two people to
cause meaning in the worst of
circumstances would be a very strong
juxtaposition to the injustice that the
movie was telling Alan when you go after
David grands story in The New Yorker
what are the steps to get it from
publication in the magazine to developed
to actually produced what was that
journey like and how difficult was it
because obviously this is not standard
studio fair only nine years the
beginning was quite interesting because
I have a development fund so I read the
article and thought this is a fantastic
movie and I called CAA and they said
well there's other clients that wanted
so you're going to be down the line and
I said
tell whomever it is that wants to buy it
that I would like to do it and maybe
they know me and it was at whoever
thirty years by the grace of God and
it's like are you kidding let's just do
this together which is obviously an
incredibly amazing blessing because it
took nine years to make it and I think
thirty years of friendship kept us going
I want to ask you about what has
happened since David Graham's reporting
ended there's been a frontline special
about this case and a documentary called
incendiary the Willingham case was there
more information that came out through
the development of this project through
your own research that added to what
David Grant's amazing reporting already
at establish well certainly Barry Scheck
in the Innocence Project had accumulated
a remarkable amount after the fact but
mostly what we had we had Elizabeth
Gilbert as a source and she was
exceedingly generous with us and gave us
all of her correspondence with Todd and
all of his correspondence with her so
Laura I would I just add one quick thing
but in truth it's been a horror show
because every time we thought that the
Texas science forensics Commission
decided that it was faulty evidence and
we thought okay finally he's going to be
exonerated
a judge in Navarro County wrote a whole
opinion that he should be exonerated
shut down every single time since we
started working on the article there
have been numerous occasions when he
could have been exonerated and it has
just been swept away I hate to ask this
but isn't that in some ways make this
point of the film more relevant yeah
well I mean look though I think we have
a much greater sense of injustice right
now at this political moment than we
have ever had in the country I think we
have an unindicted co-conspirator who is
the President of the United States I
think we are aware of a disproportionate
distribution of income I think there's
so many reasons for us to actually have
some greater consciousness about
unfairness Laura I want to ask about Liz
and about me
is that something you were willing to do
reluctant to do and what you took away
from that beyond the gift of the letters
what was your impression about how she
saw herself in a story and how her view
of herself in this story evolved well I
first want to say how blessed I feel
that these amazing people to my left and
right invited me on this journey and you
know it's hard not to fall in love with
the idea of Liz but Liz refuted that she
was the most idyllic muse I think for
both myself and Ed if I may because with
that refusal to be Mother Teresa
she kept us I think very well in
constant search for honesty and and
availability to anyone who would witness
this story she said which I really loved
in our first conversation and our
conversation started and obviously she
does not travel easily and so she and I
started by phone conversations and
skyping together and her sharing all the
letters which was so amazing and
generous and one of the first things she
shared with me was she said you know I
don't know what you guys are thinking
but I just want to be clear I had seen
this you know a group of people getting
on buses to go to this rally and they
wanted to stand up to abolish the death
penalty and it was grandmothers and
teenagers and so many different kinds of
people fighting for this one cause and I
thought that was really interesting and
I learned that there was this program in
which you could write a letter to a
death row inmate and she said you know
there was that moment like well I'm in
between writing a play you know my kids
are growing up I've got a minute maybe I
can do this thing in fact
feel good because I've got 10 minutes I
want to feel like a good person and I
loved that she offered that sort of
seemingly I'm gonna Pat myself on the
back and be you know doing something
that's sort of an act of service she
said please make sure there's a feeling
of that in the movie that this isn't
this extraordinary person who did this
thing she was like I'm just like
everybody else is like huh why not okay
maybe that's nice
you know what now we've written letters
let me go visit him nobody else is
visiting but then you're your own
internal investment occurs when your
heart gets cracked open and you see the
loneliness of the place and you witness
the horror of death row and then
ultimately as it started to unfold she
started to have a feeling that there was
more to this story and you very
intentionally I would suspect follow the
pattern of David Grant's article and
that is if you read David's story for
the first half of it you think he's
guilty that you as the director put the
audience in the eyes of the jury and I
wonder why that was important to you
because it's important to David as a
journalist it's also important to you as
a director it is because I felt that
that what happened to Todd had to do
with an objectification or a
demonization that is also very common he
is the other and he's the thing that
society wants to blame and get rid of
and I think for us to form that same
judgment is to make us all we the
audience complicit and therefore I think
it's only because of that complicity can
you then take all the ride must you take
all the ride and be forced to see the
result Alan I'm going to ask you about
making this movie because one of the
last credits we saw was shot in Georgia
that's a conversation we can have later
but did you try to shoot it somewhere
else and never enjoyed you did you try
to go to Texas and was that was that a
possibility and if not why not
interestingly when we were first
mounting the production of someone that
I knew from some time before we'd made a
film together
was then had become the head of the
Texas Film Commission so I sent her the
screenplay and we actually really like
each other she rang me up and she said
you can't come here it's not safe and I
said these are words that are never
spoken by a phone Commissioner you can't
come here what was the concern I have to
say it's not safe well this is a very
provocative story obviously in Texas and
there's been a huge cover-up so there's
a lot invested in keeping it covered up
Allen Laura Ned thanks so much for
bringing us your film